Speaker 1: Republican leaders across the
country have been knocking Joe Biden for the
high inflation rate and the looming recession,
saying that if only we had a steady hand in the
White House, if only we had Republican leadership,
we wouldn't be in all these different problems.
But unfortunately for them, these red states are
dealing with inflation, too. And in many of these
areas, within these red states, the inflation
rates are above the national average. Like, for
example, in Texas, we have Governor Greg Abbott
who's been attacking Joe Biden for inflation. But
if you look at the inflation rate in the Houston
area, it's 10.2% and it's 9.4% in the Dallas area,
which is quite a bit higher than the national
average of 8.5%. Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
and Georgia Governor Brian Kemp have also
been knocking Biden for the inflation rate,
even though in the Miami area inflation
is at 10.6%, in Tampa, 11.2%, and Atlanta,
11.5%. But at the same time, many of these same
Republicans who are attacking Biden for inflation,
they're taking credit for the strong jobs numbers
that are happening in their states. The Associated
Press found a familiar pattern in 15 Republican
led states in which governors on Twitter would
praise job growth in their states. So like,
for example, we have Governor Greg Abbott from
Texas. He was saying last month, quote, The U.S.
economy is in a recession under Biden. Meanwhile,
Texas was number one in the nation for
job growth in June. And more Texans have
jobs today than ever before in our state's
history. Now, even though it's dishonest,
it actually does make sense for these Republican
governors to make the case from a political
standpoint that the economy is so great in their
states, but in the toilet nationally. And that's
because voters tend to not be able to see through
it. They hold the state economy and the national
economy to different standards. Let's say you're
in Florida and things are not going so well for
you. You're going to be more likely to blame
Joe Biden for the inflation rate, gas prices,
what have you. Then you would be Governor Ron
DeSantis. You don't think that the census has
much to do with it, but if you extend this logic
a little bit further, you see how absurd it is,
right? Because you could look beyond the state,
you could look beyond the country and just look
at things from the world level. And you would
understand that the entire world right now is
dealing with inflation in some form. It's just one
of those things where we're trying to get back on
track post the pandemic. And if you look at the
European Union, they have to raise interest rates
now because their inflation rate is at a sky high
8.9%. Canada also has high inflation. They're at
7.6%. This is not a issue that is unique to the
United States, but because so many Americans and
Republicans especially seem to be unaware that
there is a world outside of the U.S., it's not
just all about us. And all of our economies are
interconnected because they don't realize that.
They just think that the buck stops with Biden
entirely on this which which it doesn't. And,
you know, it's not like you can just pass some
policy or decide to spend less money or whatever
and poof, the inflation problem would be gone.
It's a lot more complicated that than that. And,
you know, the truth is governors nor presidents
have much to do with a lot of these economic
indicators, like inflation, like gas prices.
And we'd be much better served if the general
public knew that. But for now, with the public
being ignorant on it, Republicans are able to
take advantage of the public cigarets and keep
winning elections, unfortunately. We're going
to go to a quick break. We'll be back with much
more of The David Pakman Show right after this.